from magnus carlsen
you predicted a king's pawn opening we
were talking about an offbeat opening
this is as offbeat as they come i've
never seen this from a top level
grandmaster in a serious event
if we have that recorder if we can
actually see magnus's reaction after
making that first move once again i just
want to
see if if we are okay
what do you think okay like this or was
it planned okay what's happening i mean
they've been making moves thick and fast
uh black actually developed in the
center with his own pawn
and there has been a trade the first
pawn that white pushed the orangutan
opening that has been snapped off the
board as well but in return
magnus gaining his central pawn so a
trade of pawns already at this early
stage
magnus now attacking black's bishop
which was developed
so magnus just trying to kick that away
with the pawn i think it wasn't a mouse
slip
i think i've seen this position before
and magnus wouldn't have
followed up his mouse well mouse lip so
quickly are we seeing some
clever preparation do you think i i've
seen some experts play this
actually with reverse colors the same
opening but with reverse colors and
they like to push support in just one
square to kick that bishop back
um i think the idea is that white bishop
which looks very nice and very
centralized right now
will trade itself off for a night later
so you want to put your pawns on dark
squares as white
because you're going to give up your
dark square bishop um what is this so is
it are we still in the orangutan
this is in some once you've been
swinging with this orangutans you can't
turn back
and okay magnus making a face there
surprised by giri's move
uh now the blood the white bishop was
attacked in the center it trades itself
off
for a night we see a trade there so
magnus with that orangutan opening spent
three moves with his bishop but it's
disappeared from the board so he's lost
a lot of time black ahead in development
black with the two bishops now look at
white pieces none of them have moved
he needs to start getting those pieces
he needs to just
somehow get them into the center get
them controlling some squares but
magnus um why is it not a fan of the
sibling why is it called orangutan
opening
do we know um i wish i knew i i don't
actually know
um i can find it most openings they're
named after
maybe prominent players who've used that
opening who've um
kind of been cheerleaders for that
opening or they're named after places
where their opening have
uh have been played the london system
the french defense that kind of thing
but
the orangutan it's one of the odd ones
i'm a big fan of the hippopotamus
opening that one i can say why but the
orangutan
kai has asked the question that's
actually i've been dying to know the
answer
why is it called the orangutan opening
and you can just see actually
on the board that magnus is continuing
with his strategy of placing
all the pawns on dark squares those
pawns are going to be
a wall against that dark squared bishop
but
i'm guessing that it will go on to other
pastures perhaps put pressure on the
center
and anish is kind of playing my favorite
strategy in the opening which is a light
square strategy bringing the pawns on
light squares and it's going to be all
about that light squared bishop
okay i was going to say he's probably
going to castle but instead he decides
to occupy the center
with his pawns and um yeah i mean we we
mentioned
ivanka um that we aren't really aware of
the origins of the name the orangutan
opening i mean that just shows how rare
it is right most openings we can say why
it's called that
and what the ideas are here it's so rare
um
that um yeah the origins of the openings
name at least
maybe it's a bit wild you know like the
orangutan
and the last move was not too wild latch
is developing a bishop there
but okay well maybe it was after okay so
the the nights have now been developed
but uh i was just thinking about the
origin maybe it's from uh
edgar allan poe's uh story the murder
story
but it turns out the orangutan did it
yeah so
magnus's um plan behind that first move
must have been to surprise the niche to
put him off
has he succeeded that's we're also
seeing another move probably he should
have been trying to punish magnus's
opening
but um yeah on the clock at least
anushka is in good shape and now we do
see a trade of pawns
yeah i agree with you david um somehow
from this wild
start we now have a very classical
position where magnus has
occupied the center and there's nice
nice squares for the pieces and
anish it's all about that dark square
bishop and at the minute that
is just jammed in by this wall of white
pawns
um yeah and definitely i feel that
magnus's opening has
been a success i would say um right now
giri spending a bit of time does improve
the black queen
that black queen now has side steps so
the black rooks are connected that's one
thing we always want to do in chess
connect our rooks
it gives a lot more flexibility for them
especially on the back rank
to slide across to open lines sensible
play by gary but
now i expect to see magnus carlsen do
the same the white queen not doing too
much
she needs to find a better square and
once she does i think white
is pretty happy white has two central
pawns against
black's none and at this early stage in
the game at least
those central pawns are very nice at
blocking in black's bishops okay magnus
instead of moving his queen he does
first
uh plants the white rook on the same
line as the black queen and black does
the same black plays copycat
planting the black rook opposite the
white queen
yeah magnus on that subject has now
moved his knight forward
and just i just love the way these two
knights are positioned you know they're
really eyeing up the center and again
reinforcing the potential advance and i
say use the potential advance of these
white pawns
uh attacking things but as soon as
things start to open up those knights
will cause havoc and that's why nhgri
he's trying to trade off
one of the strong knights that you
highlighted kaya yeah one of white's
knights
might have to trade itself off for
blacks more in terms of pressure rather
than anything actually
material in concrete i would have to
agree i think white's position
at least for now is easier to play
magnus does go for that trade of knights
uh i'm slightly surprised that he rushed
with it i think there was no need
you could have just waited for black to
spend the move uh trading those nights
so you want to keep white's pawn
structure fully intact you want to play
with pieces not pawns
and that's why magnus brings his queen
to the side of the board the more
frustrated anishigiri will become
because the black bishops
do as ivanka mentioned they do lack
targets right now
one of them is hitting thin air the
other black bishop hitting against a
very
fortified white pawn and anishigiri for
once of a better thing to do
just pushes the pawn in front of his
king making sure that the king has some
breathing space there will be no
back rank checkmates later on yeah and
whilst uh magnus pond does that i do
have uh one suggestion okay we just have
to take this move
so uh uh did you see gary's face
uh when magnus lifted that rook up uh
giri looked shocked
but i did mention white needs to improve
his work so that move makes a lot of
sense to me
magnus just lifting his rook he wants to
slide it across one move one square to
the left
next to kick away black's queen yeah
well kevin
winter says that it's an opening name by
tartakova as an old player
after he consulted the orangutan susan
at
bronx zoo the monkey suggested
b the b4 is the coordinates of the move
wow oh that's such a cool story yeah
meanwhile black has just
moved his bishop trying to eliminate the
white knight uh we did mention that the
black bishops don't really have a
purpose
black is trying to exchange that off but
he doesn't have time yet
anish giri is in trouble i think white's
there bringing the rook across kicking
away the black queen
trying to hit the black queen at least
we saw on giri's face he's not happy
he knows that this orangutan it has uh
it has tricked him
bring up the analysis board we can see
that it's in the current position
after black moved his bishop to try and
eliminate this knight magnus ignored it
magnus just shifted his rook across and
now black's queen is in big trouble she
doesn't want to
trade herself off for white's queen
because suddenly if we see a queen
exchange
look at how ugly these black pawns are
now they're shattered
uh they're divided they're isolated
they're easy pickings
for white pieces so if you can't trade
queens what else do you
what else can you do you have to retreat
surely this is what anishigiri is
thinking about but once you retreat
okay which anishikiri does you lose
protection of this pawn magnus
doesn't hesitate he takes that pawn off
the board that's why white has a plus
one advantage
he's simply a pawn up and why
threatening a second pawn with his rook
and with his queen magnus in control
here yeah okay
and uh well anisha is being forced onto
the defensive there he is
moving his rook one square up just to
defend the pawn
long term being that one pawn down and
having no real counter play
it does i mean it doesn't bode well for
geary fans
okay and now we have a decision yeah
magnus has retweeted his night and now
would you capture that night because
that night is headed yep okay
well anish says absolutely and uh
now there is something to be hateful
about and that is the presence of
opposite colored bishops
we can see what magnus castle is
thinking about anishigiri pushing this
pawn forward
trying to uh trying to undermine white's
strongest pawn
um white's important we should mention
cannot take because this
it would be a pin this rook would be
undefended white would lose a piece here
and
as you've predicted ivanka he slides
across his rook instead so this rook
which was undefended
now creates a pin of its own uh these
rooks on these open lines they're so
good at tying down the opponent's forces
and um
we do see a trade of queens right now
but magnus he has
plenty of choice here he could trade a
set of pawns but there's no rush maybe
you just bring your remaining rook
into the game that rook doing nothing
and you're eyeing up weak pawns
yes there are opposite colour bishops
but as long as rooks remain on the board
black is still far far away from holding
the draw here
and you can definitely imagine a
scenario where white starts pushing this
pawn maybe if you can eliminate this guy
note how white's corner pawn once he
gets to the end of the board it
is going to promote on a square that's
guarded by white's bishop so that's the
long-term plan
to try and win this game for white this
pawn blocks in white's bishop but
secondly
you can imagine black just blockading
this pawn quite easily on dark squares
that's why opposite color bishops have
such a drawing tendency
because you can blockade on one color
complex and okay that's why magnus
carson didn't
uh hurry to push his pawns and now
instead bring his rook across and he's
going to be forced to just defend this
guy
this pawn here it's not looking good for
geary
but uh yep some games has some moves
have been played
and magnus doing what magnus loves to do
piling on the pressure he's advanced
upon two squares
and he's getting ready to potentially
destabilize
those two black pawns on the left side
he's spending time finally but that's
because it's hard to even find
one productive move how do you feel
about magnus's play in this game after
that surprise opening
schmooze yeah smooth he's never looked
back he had one strategy in mind
that was to um to gain these central
pawns he undermined black central pawns
he got rid of those he kept his center
intact it's still there
for now white's very strong center and
uh yeah magnus he's been very consistent
with his
with his strategy meanwhile and he's
just retreating a bishop there trying to
pin white central pawn
i don't see any reason why not to just
maybe shift up that white rook
which does lie on the same diagonal as
black bishop just move that piece maybe
just shift it up one square
you don't want your pieces to be targets
for uh the opponent's bishop but
okay magnus retreating his bishop i'm
surprised by that one that wasn't on my
radar at least
um it looked like that but it was on a
fantastic diagonal
um is actually to move this piece
because right now you want to play pawn
takes pawn
in the center of the board but the rook
behind it would hang the rook is loose
and undefended
so if you can move this piece for
example i'm not sure the best square but
for example if you shift it across
line up your rooks now everything is
ganged up against
this square white has to release this
tension white has to play pawn takes
pawn now
and maybe black's best would be to
capture this white rook
and after a few trades we see yes white
is still a pawn up
but at least now you have clarified some
tension for black
you're one step closer to your goal as
black okay he finds this move
and if we reach this position that i'm
showing on the analysis board then
suddenly magnus's chances of winning i
think
have diminished suddenly black can even
plant his bishop on this square to
protect
this weak pawn and how are you going to
make progress with white yes
you don't have any weaknesses yes you
can maybe try and coordinate activate
the white rook the white bishop
but you don't have any past pawns at
least and without past pawns in an end
game it's always
incredibly difficult to win so i think
anish with this last move
finding this move this one lining up his
rooks together i think he's found a
great defensive try
probably the best of a bun of uh best
possible move
in that difficult position um carlson
but he didn't spot this last move as
your vanco mentioned and
okay pawn takes porn this is what we
showed on the analysis board a moment
ago
we do see that series of traits and
that's why magnus castle was thinking
that a moment ago
he saw three four moves ahead and uh he
went through that
kind of simplification process those
exchanges now he's attacking black's
bishop trying to kick it away
once black black's bishop retreats
white's rook is going to activate itself
along the open line it's going to maybe
jump up to the seventh rank that's where
rooks love to be
yeah i was thinking the position is
still not very pleasant for
anish um okay so he had didn't move the
bishop in fact he protected it with his
rook
and magnus completely unfazed he just
slides his rook to the
new open line that's now become
available and the plan is still
very much in action he wants to put his
rook on the seventh line
and from there he will put pressure on
those pawns that are conveniently
situated
on light squares it's going to be
relevant for the next 10 20 moves i
think
uh magnus now bringing his rook to the
open line but the rook is destined
for a better square if blacks just plays
too slowly if for example he approves
his king
then the white rook will jump up seventh
heaven the seventh rank where all the
pawns lie
and this is the target later on white's
bishop will try it can't right now but
he'll want to try and gang up on this
pawn
it's all about this pawn right now and
that's why any girly finds a better move
he
brings his rook back because this is
white's target this is the piece
this is the pawn that white wants to
target with the rook and the bishop so
black now
stopping the white rook from invading
and protecting it
uh great defense by andy shkiri and
after white's rook jumped up
the black bishop protects this pawn
right now gary he's in passive mode
he's kind of uh he's just in lockdown
mode trying to defend everything
but okay so far he has been able to
survive this
uh this long a long step towards
knockout stage yeah
no probably actually in big trouble as
well in terms of qualification and
okay magnus just improving the white
bishop there note how both
bishops they're protecting pawns but
they're also protected by pawns
and that just gives some solidity some
stability to your position
that's often a good idea in these end
games so um
i would be thinking about picking up my
pawn your corner pawn
yeah my that one the harry the h pawn
and i would be
picking it up and moving it two squares
okay but anish chooses instead to
improve
his king and uh it's now on the second
row
but what's to stop magnus from just
advancing one of his pawns on the king
side on the right side
i think black should have taken that
opportunity to push his corner pawn
forward push harry to the edge pawn
because
you might not get that opportunity
anymore okay magnus doesn't choose that
one he chooses to advance his kingspawn
um that's normally a good move on move
one magnus normally plays that on move
one
this time he didn't and he saved it for
move 35
so pushing his king's pawn forward there
okay
makes some sense as well he's trying to
push that as far as it can go
that actually is the only um that's the
only pawn that black can never counter
long term
that's where white's advantage lies with
the king's pawn so black gives a check
and he has occupied the seventh rank now
yeah let's bring up the analysis board
because there's actually an immediate
threat in the position and as you
mentioned this is the pawn this is the
target now for black
it's eyed up by the black rook but more
importantly if white is just complacent
if white just
takes the time out to push some pawns
suddenly black bishop could come into
the game it looked offside there but
suddenly the bishop
has got targets he's ganging up teaming
up with the black rook and
white's pawns are starting to fall but
even if you stop this plan even if for
example you drop your king back
uh ivanka's idea is not to use that
square but to relocate this bishop to
another diagonal to bring it
back this way and but david he don't
care
magnus says he's doing something else
so he's pushed his pawn in the center
forward and
it looks like he might not care that was
my first initial impression but there is
a kind of idea and the idea is that
if david sorry if black were to play
the bishop move then suddenly that pawn
has now secured a square for the white
rook
and uh magnus can now defend the pawn
yeah so magnus had to defend this but it
does feel a bit rushed there was no
reason
uh for magnus to i think in this
position there was no reason to push
this pawn forward he's just given
activity to the black rook you should
have stopped the blackfoot coming into
the position because now
currently in the position we have on the
board suddenly at least black has one
active piece and once this
bishop gets active i think this is
actually a good move right now attacking
the rook
and uh trying to line up on this
diagonal once black does this
at least both of black's pieces are
active it's going to be so hard
to break down well for white to defend
his pawns
while continuing to make progress and uh
in end games it's all about activity you
can't just sit slowly
uh you can't sit passively and let your
opponent build up and do whatever they
want you have to create threats of your
own
even in situations like this where
you're pawn down and giri he does
find this move there's actually a trick
in the position as well if white plays
rook takes pawn then black will not
retreat his bishop
because white can slide across and
defend this pawn instead black will
sacrifice his rook
this is a common trick when your
opponent's pieces are on the same color
as your bishop black will sacrifice on
this square
check and after king takes rook now we
have a fork a double attack
black's bishop checks the king and we'll
next move gobble up that white rook
restoring uh well winning back to rook
and only one pawn down
and opposite colour bishops without
rooks should be a draw that's why magnus
carson avoids that trick he brings his
rook across
to defend this pawn but he can't be
happy magnus the last few moves have not
gone in his favor giri defending
really really resolutely anishikari he's
quite likely to hold this game i think
he might
save this one um still no risk for
carson
giri is fighting for the draw it's a two
result game
either white will win or it's a draw
black will never win this one but
chances of a draw have increased a lot
over the last few moves
now giri attacking the white rook and
trying to set up that trick again
rook takes porn he's allowed this magnus
carson he's played rook takes pawn i
thought this
was something he didn't want to do
because now blacks rook
is going to take that pawn with check um
no chances
okay wow okay well you just said that he
would move his king away
and uh you were wrong david i was wrong
uh the rooks have disappeared
now magnus he's still one porn up white
has an extra corner pawn here
but opposite color bishops um yeah it's
gonna be hard to break down
black's blockade of those dark squares
white trying to go active
with his king i expect to see black's
king now try to relocate itself
that black's king was not doing anything
tucked away in the corner there so the
black king rushing over to the left side
okay it's a race can magnus carson
promote his corner pawn if he can't push
it over the next few moves
it's going to be a dead draw so can i
give you set up a blockade
in the meantime well he's trying he mean
the blockade will happen on the dark
squares and
you can see anish has mobilized his king
basically the action for the black king
will happen on the right side of the
board
and it will try to gobble up and win as
many pawns as possible
so so what would you play here now i
think black can uh
black just wait with his bishop okay he
tries to initiate a trade of pawns
um going for that strategy that you
mentioned ivanka eliminating pawns only
helps black
magnus he pretty much has to trade a set
of pawns he has to allow a set of trades
because if you pushed your pawn up one
square it would have been on a dark
square it wouldn't easy pickings for the
black bishop
what black should do just trade a center
pawns here eliminate as many points as
possible and just drop the bishop back
keep the bishop on this square okay he
doesn't do that but if you keep the
bishop on this way you keep white's king
honest you keep white's king
having to defend this pawn and you stop
the advance of white spawn
here so nothing to do white cannot do
anything there's no progress to be made
instead andy curry blocks the pawn from
this angle
and maybe he'll plant the bishop on this
square instead from where it
keeps an eye on this pawn um yeah i
think
magnus he's lost the thread here he
needed to keep rooks on the board
without rooks opposite colour bishops
it's just too drawish
for aneesh to sorry yeah i need to
respond to that
he has he has moved his bishop and just
know how the bishop is just
staying fixed on that diagonal and it's
keeping an eye on that
corner pawn on the left and now magnus
is just simply moving the bishop around
i i just think there's no way to make
progress at
all we see another move oh okay
it is a really cool picture as well
nothing's changing though the bishops
are just maneuvering dancing around well
i do have a cool picture from joe gather
cole
he says me and the class love to watch
the streams nearing the end hours of the
day
and there is a picture with uh joe and
the class
waving the picture yes sir so while
we're waiting
for the picture there it is oh that's so
cool
i know definitely and there's school
uniforms so i uh
cool yeah hi to all of you fantastic
that you're following
okay meanwhile just nothing had changed
much until this last move by magnus
magnus offering a trade of pawns but
once this set of pawns disappear
now we're heading towards that draw
magnus now will play bishop takes pawn
but
all black needs to do is plant his
remaining pawn on a dark square
black's pawn push it okay first he
brings the black king over to that left
side
actually they just agree a draw there
was just no way through to break black's
blockade
white's extra pawn didn't count for
anything and anishigiri
saves the game